as laura said earlier this week the
blanket reverence that the alphabet
organizations have enjoyed over the
years is now gone between their actions
during the trump presidency the 2020
election the whitmer kidnapping case and
potentially january 6 the fbi is largely
and correctly being seen as out of
control
as meta ceo mark zuckerberg let slip in
a podcast with joe rogan the fbi told
facebook a russian disinformation drop
was coming and then the hunter biden
laptop stories started coming
the fbi i think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was
we we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be
some kind of dump of of um
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant fewer people saw it than would
have otherwise
the corrupt action of the fbi is one
thing but just as troubling is that all
of biden's policies that have followed
followed seem to reinforce what we
learned from the laptop on china the
president is completely beholden to them
hunter had contacts for major
influencers on china policy he tagged
along when joe went there and met with
chinese businessman and joe had a 10
equity stake in cefc a china ccp linked
china energy company
joining me now is indiana congressman
jim banks chairman of the republican
study committee and florida congressman
mike waltz
congressman banks i'll start with you
the fbi wasn't just interfering in an
election and meddling in partisan
politics but in suppressing the laptop
story are they also endangering our
national security
without a doubt remember two months
before the new york post wrote the story
about the hunter biden laptop nancy
pelosi was calling it russian
disinformation they didn't want the
contents of that laptop to be public
information because they know it would
have swayed the election away from joe
biden and donald trump would have been
re-elected the contents of the laptop
tell us that hunter biden received
somewhere around 31 million dollars from
companies tied to the chinese communist
party our biggest adversary he received
a 80 000
diamond from one of these uh figures and
we know that 10 percent was being
skimmed off the top for the big guy
rachel i think i know who the big guy is
but why isn't the fbi digging into that
why aren't they raiding the home of the
big guy
to expose the link between the biden
family and our biggest adversaries that
we face in america today that being the
chinese communist party i think we know
the answer to that question yeah it's
such a great point congressman it
wouldn't be hard for them to do a
forensic audit and see if the money from
hunter um ends up in in in in joe
biden's bank account or paying for some
of his bills um that that has not been
done it's such an excellent point
congressman walt zuckerberg's company
meta is already trying to walk back his
comments and tweeting in part quote as
we've said nothing about the hunter
biden laptop story is new the fbi shared
general warnings about foreign
interference nothing specific about
hunter biden
congressman walt will you call mark
zuckerberg uh before congress to answer
more questions on this
we will rachel when we get in the
majority and i think the thing that has
so many americans so upset is just the
total lack of accountability for these
big tech executives you've got jack
dorsey of twitter
who says yeah it was a mistake
to block the hunter biden story months
before the election completely block it
ban anybody from sharing it oops just
shrugs his shoulders and now you've got
zuckerberg you know basically saying
yeah this that sucked it's kind of like
you know a murder trial where we find
out they didn't do it oh well seriously
really but to your you know to your
point how is this you know really now
compromising our national security and
the thing that has me so
alarmed
is
we know the chinese communist party
doesn't just give someone 1.5 billion
as they gave hunter biden to invest in i
don't know t-shirt factories
they want investments in artificial
intelligence and nanotechnology and
advanced materials
and so what key technologies did hunter
invest in we know that right now he is
an equity holder in a chinese nuclear uh
a nuclear energy company that has been
blacklisted for trying to steal
american nuclear weapons technology did
he influence export controls in some way
given his influence with the big guy
those are the questions we have to and
we absolutely will and i know jim banks
is going to be all over this with a
republican study committee when we get
the majority back in congress yeah i
mean these aren't political questions
these are absolutely national security
questions that must be answered
congressman banks
not only did the fbi and i just want to
say what you said to congressman waltz
also at the very beginning of your
answer it is disturbing how casually uh
mark zuckerberg talks about interference
with our election i mean it's just it's
it's astounding uh congressman banks you
know they didn't just interfere with the
with with the election they also put
people who protested that interference
um you know in prison uh you know
american citizens what are you going to
do about that
well from from day one when we get the
majority back uh come january we have a
moral responsibility to investigate the
actions the very political actions of
the biden department of justice so you
look at this this hundred byte
laptop censorship issue it's just like
the russian collusion hoax which was
cooked up in the obama white house by
the way it was it was a a combination of
of democrat uh politicians working with
democrat figures in the department of
justice and the fbi to cook up russian
collusion hoax or to censor the hundred
biden laptop if there's ever if there's
ever going to be the right guy in the
right place at the right time it's going
to be jim jordan chairing the house
judiciary committee oversight of the doj
who's going to haul these guys in before
the committee and force them to testify
and hold them accountable
excellent point i hope that happens
congressman banks congressman waltz
thanks for joining us hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else